AGE RODRIGUEZ HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM CONSENT AND WILL BE PART OF
THE REGULAR SESSION.
I ALSO KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
COMMITTEES GOING ON IF YOU WERE
GONNA BE IN AND OUT BUT FOR NOW
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK MISTER
RODRIGUEZ TWO COMMA.
MOVING FORWARD WE ARE GOING TO
START US AS A SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL
WE CAN GET A QUORUM [inaudible]
ARE YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT AB.
FIVE FORTY EIGHT THE EARTHQUAKE
BREAKS AND BOLT PROGRAM OFFERS
CALIFORNIANS UP TO THREE
THOUSAND AND INSTEAD OF GROUNDS
TO RETROFIT THE EARTHQUAKE BONTA
BROUGH HOMES.
CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
ARE SELECTED THREE LOTTERY STONE
SELECTION PROCESS WHICH DOES NOT
CONSIDER INCOME AS A CONDITION
OF ACCEPTANCE.
UNFORTUNATELY MOST RECTOR FOR
ITS COST WELL OVER THREE
THOUSAND WHILE THERE ARE
HOMEOWNERS WHO CAN.
SURE THE EXTRA COST THIS POSES
AN OBSTACLE FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS.
IN ADDITION TO THE NATIONAL
THREE THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANT.
THE SUPPLEMENT GRANT WILL
PROVIDE A LOW INCOME HOMEOWNER
WOULD 90% OF RETRO FOR COST.
BOB REPORT BY PROVIDING THE
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT TO LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS AB FIVE FORTY EIGHT
WELL ALL CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
INCOME LEVELS TO FULLY UTILIZE
IT.
EARTHQUAKE BOAT -- PROGRAM.
WITH HERE WITH ME TODAY IS GLENN
POMEROY FROM THE EARTHQUAKE.
AUTHORITY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT.
YES ESERVER -- RUBIO AND AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AT THAT
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY
THE BOARD TO THE GOVERNING BOARD
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER.
THE TREASURER AND THE GOVERNOR
SORRY AND YOU SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
MEASURE AND ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD AND OUR STAFF WE WILL TAKE
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO AND IMPLEMENTING THIS
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO SPEAK PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MADISON
BY ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN RED
CROSS AND SUPPORT.
YOU CAN.
MIKE MARTINEZ HER BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER CARD A
LOT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HM.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
WITH HAT SAID -- WILL MOVE ON
TO THE ARGUMENT IN OPPOSITION.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
HEARING NO INTEREST -- QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MR MARLA -- THANK YOUR CINNAMON
RODRIGUEZ FOR INDULGING ME.
OUR MISTER POMEROY MAYBE I COULD
ASK YOU -- FOR THE C. E. A THE
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY.
IS.
A FIVE OH ONE C. THREE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION -- NO CENTER THE
THE SEA IS A CREATURE OF STATE
STATUTE AND THAT WAS ESTABLISHED --
BACK IN THE MID NINETIES AT ONE
OF THE FIRST THINGS HE DID WAS
APPROACH THE INTERNAL REVENUE
SERVICE. TO RECEIVE A PRIVATE
LETTER RULING SO WE ARE TAX
EXEMPT BUT NOT WE ARE NOT
TECHNICALLY FIVE ONE C..
THREE WERE TEXAS THAT BY VIRTUE
OF A PRIVATE LETTER RULING FROM
THE IRS.
AND IS IS ARE YOU MANDATED TO
PROVIDE GRANTS.
FOR THIS PROGRAM.
IN A SENSE THAT WOULD THAT WENT
THE AUTHORIZING LEGISLATION FOR
THE C..
EIGHT CORRECTED THAT 5% OF OUR
INVESTMENT INCOME.
UP TO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
BE USED TO FUND MITIGATION
EFFORTS IN CALIFORNIA THE THAT
WAS PARTY NAMELY STATUES BACK IN
THE MID NINETIES.
SO IN THAT THIS ORGANIZATION
TRIED A NUMBER OF THINGS OVER
THE YEARS TO FULFILL THAT
MANDATE -- BACK IN -- WITH HE
WAS TWENTY FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWELVE OR THIRTEEN WOULD BE IN A
DEVELOP THIS EARTHQUAKE
BREATHABLE PROGRAM TO TO TO TO
GIVE MEANING TO THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS.
AND SINCE THEN HAVE DEVELOPED
THIS PROGRAM -- RETREATED EIGHT
THOUSAND HOMES SO FAR.
AS A RESULT OF THE EARTHQUAKE
REASONABLE PROGRAM -- FOUR
THOUSAND AND IN THE IN LA COUNTY
AND FOURTH ON THE NORTH.
AND OUR INTEREST IS TO CONTINUE
TO GROW INTO MORE [inaudible]
BUT THEN.
THIS THIS GRANT PROGRAM IS PART
OF YOUR MANDATE BUT IT ISN'T FOR
OUR ANY [inaudible]
INTERNAL REVENUE.
SERVICE PURPOSES IS JUST.
PART OF THE CREATION.
AND AND YOU COULD PROBABLY DO
OTHER PROGRAMS BESIDES BRACE
SYMBOL.
WE DO OTHER MITIGATION PROGRAMS --
AS SECTION ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT
NINE POINT THREE SEVEN IS THE
PROVISION OF THE LAW THAT
ESTABLISHES THIS EARTHQUAKE LOSS
MITIGATION FUND.
DIRECTS AT 5% OF OUR INVESTMENT
INCOME UP TO FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR WHICHEVER IS LESS
GO INTO THAT FUND.
AND THEN -- THE INDICATES THAT.
ARE THAT OF THOSE FUNDS WE ARE
TO PROMOTE MITIGATION.
AND AS A PART OF OUR IRIS TAXES
AND RULING.
THE PART OF WHAT.
ALLOW THE IRIS TO VIEW US AS A
PUBLIC.
NOT PROFIT AN ENTERPRISE
THEREFORE WORTHY OF A NOT OF A
TAX EXEMPT STATUS.
WAS -- THE INDICATION THAT THESE
FUNDS WOULD BE MAILED MADE
AVAILABLE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS --
NOT LIMITED TO THOSE WHO HAVE A
CA POLICY SO.
IT'S A COMBINATION OF STATUTORY
LAW IRIS.
THE RULING AND EXPRESSED -- SEE
INTENT THAT WE ARE WHERE WE ARE
TODAY.
FUNDS AVAILABLE TO MITIGATE
CALIFORNIANS ALL CALIFORNIA'S
NOT JUST THOSE WHO HAVE A
EARTHQUAKE POLICY.
OPENS FROM RIGHT NOT.
TO I GUESS THE NEXT QUESTION IS
WHY WHY THE LEGISLATION WHITE
YOU YOU ALREADY GOT AN ANTENNA
PURPOSE.
WHAT WHAT ARE WE DOING WITH THIS
BILL WHAT -- THE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IT IS THIS BILL SO AT AN
ENEMY WISHES BEFORE HIM.
BUT WE VIEW THIS AS ALTURAS I
GRAB PICKING ON YOU BUT I'M
HAPPY TO KNOW OKAY -- JUST MORE
TO HAVE MORE.
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS PROGRAM.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT WAS LIMITED
PRIOR TO THIS LEGISLATION SO I
THINK AS YOU KNOW WE LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA STATE THIS EARTHQUAKE
PRONE.
SO WE HAVE PROGRAMS LIKE THIS ISTO MAKE SURE IT'S AVAILABLE TO
MORE FOLKS AND JUST UNLIMITED.
A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS -- OUT
OF THE 5% YOU WANT TO USE SOME
OF THAT.
FOR PROMOTION AND COMMUNICATION
OF THE PROGRAM IS THAT WITH THE
THE M. -- IF I COULD COMPRESS SO
EVERY LITTLE BIT.
SO THE EARTHQUAKE BREATHABLE
PROGRAM -- PART OF THE FUNDING
CUTS TO THE PROGRAM COMES FROM
THE THIS IS THE DOLLARS THAT ARE
DIRECTED FROM THE THE FOR THE
STATUTE THE 5% OF INVESTMENT
INCOME -- ON TWO OCCASIONS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS APPROPRIATED
THREE MILLION DOLLARS EACH TIME
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO GO INTO
THIS PROGRAM.
AND OCCASIONALLY FEMA HAS
AWARDED GRANTS -- THEY ALSO GO
IN THIS PROGRAM.
THE PROGRAM IS JOINTLY
ADMINISTERED BY THE CA AND THE
CALLAWAY US THROUGH IT -- GPA.
AND AND IS SO YOU LOOK AT THAT
IT AND WHATEVER FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE AS THE FOR IN THE IS
THE FUNDING SOURCE FOR THESE
GRANTS.
THE FUNNY SEVERELY LIMITED THESE
GRANTS COSTS -- SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN FOUR THOUSAND AND SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS REGARDED
DEPENDING ON WHERE THE HOME IS
LOCATED.
THE WAY WE SET UP THE PROGRAM --
BECAUSE OF LIMITED FUNDS -- WE
ESTABLISH SOME PRIORITIES -- ZIP
CODES ARE RANKED ONE THROUGH
HOWEVER MANY ZIP CODES ARE BASED
ON TWO FIVE TWO CATEGORIES.
ONE HIGH CONCENTRATION OF US
SEISMIC RISK.
AND TO THE HIGH CONCENTRATION OF
OLD BUILDING STOCKS.
IN WHEN WE STARTED THIS PROGRAM
BACK IN TWENTY THIRTEEN OR
FOURTEEN I THINK IT WAS -- WE
STARTED WITH WITH THE TOP FOUR
ZIP CODES IT WAS THOSE TWO
CATEGORIES ARE SMASHED TOGETHER.
AND WE'RE WE'RE GROWING. TO EVER
INCLUDE EVER MORE ZIP CODES ARE
GETTING MORE INTO THE TO THE
WEEDS AND I ARE WELL OKAY SORRY --
WE'RE BEING TOLD THAT IT WOULD
REQUIRE THAT WE WE AT LEAST 10%
OF THE FUNDS AVAILABLE EACH YEAR.
YES -- IN ANY YOU BEEN SAYING 5%
BUT THE BUT THE THE FUNDS
AVAILABLE ARE TO TO PROVIDE.
EDUCATION -- ARE HELPING OUT
OKAY OKAY OKAY 5% IS THE STATE'S
REMANDED FIVE CENTER INVESTMENT
INCOME NOW BUT FOR ME AND THOSE
YEAR GETS DEPOSIT IN THE LOSS
MITIGATION FUND.
THE CASE OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
APPROPRIATED ADDITIONAL FUNDS
THAT TO GO INTO FUNDING IS
PROGRAMS.
THIS LIST OF LEGISLATION WOULD
SAY WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATES.
FUNDS THE TICKET TO THESE
PROGRAMS THAT TWO THINGS HAPPEN
ONE WE ENGAGE IN SPECIFIC OUR
REACH EFFORTS TO LOW INCOME.
COMMUNITIES WHICH WE COMPLETELY
SUPPORT AND EVERYBODY WOULD WEEP
UPON THE THE THE THE DIRECTION
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
PROVIDE IN THAT REGARD.
AND 290%.
I'M SORRY. 10% OF THE GRANTS WE
WOULD ALLOW ALLOCATE THROUGH
THOSE STATE APPROPRIATE FUNDS.
WOULD BE TARGETED IT WOULD BE
THERE'D BEEN ATTEMPTED TARGET OF
HOUSEHOLDS OF LOW INCOME.
AND THREE THAT THOSE GRANTS --
CONSTITUTE 90% OF THE OF THE
AVERAGE IF IT COSTS.
YOU.
TO WRITE A LITTLE MORE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE. TO TO THE RECIPIENT
WE GOT THE PROGRAM 10% GOES TO
COMMUNICATION AND PROMOTION 90%
GOES TO THE ACTUAL [inaudible]
GRAY NO.
WERE INCREASED PROMOTE.
BUT GRANT SAID AWARDED THROUGH
THE STATE ALLOCATED MONEY-- THE
GRANT WOULD COVER 90% OF THE
COST OF THE RETROFIT IN A
HOMEOWNER WOULD KICK IN THE
REMAINING 10%.
OKAY SO WE'RE NOT.
AGAIN I GUESS WE'RE NOT.
FINDING ANY NEW MONEY OTHER THAN
WHAT OCCURS CORRECT AND EXPANDED.
AND SO AGAIN I GUESS MAYBE JUST
SUMMARIZE THIS BILL.
IN YOUR OWN WORDS JUST IN FIFTY
WORDS LEADS OR IT MIGHT ONE OF
MY APPROVING I TAKE THIS AS
LEGISLATIVE ENCOURAGEMENT.
THAT WE DO MORE TO FOCUS --
EFFORT ON LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
TO TRY TO MAKE AT LEAST A
PORTION OF OUR GRANTS --
IMPACTFUL -- TO THE PEOPLE CAN
LET LESLIE SUPPORT [inaudible]
THAT'S THAT'S A PRETTY MUCH
EXPAND IT TO THE LOW INCOME
FOLKS HAVE A BETTER OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE 9% OF THE COVERAGE OF
THE COST.
THANK YOU FOR INDULGING AGO.
THANK YOU RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU
MANAGER QUESTIONS.
OUR BEFORE WE GO FURTHER I SEE
WE HAVE -- A MORE MEMBERS
ARRIVED AFTER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
RUBIO.
BEAR WITH ME A PRESENT JONES.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA PRESENT BATES.
DATE PRESENT BURGESS.
BARGES PRESENT DODD GALGIANI
GALGIANI PRESENT GLAZIER.
GLAZER PRESENT HUESO.
HUESO PRESENT MITCHELL MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE PRESENT PORTANTINO
ROTH.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU
MAY CLOSE.
PROTESTS FROM MY ROOM THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY A MYSTERY SO.
THIS CALL THE ROLL.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE JONES I'M
SORRY THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I BATES.
BATES AYE BURGESS BURGESS AYE
DODD.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HUESO.
HUESO AYE MITCHELL.
MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE I PORTANTINO ROTH.
YOU HAVE ABLE TO AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GOING TO BE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR MEMBERS TO WRITE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SAM.
NEXT UP WE'RE GONNA HAVE AB
SEVEN FORTY BY BURKE.
SEMI BURKE YOU MAY APPROACH
THANK YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS -- FIRST I'D LIKE TO
YOURSELF FOR TAKING SO MUCH TIME
TO SIT AND TALK TO US ABOUT WHAT
THIS BILL IS AND WHERE IT'S
GOING SO I APPRECIATE THE TIME
YOU'VE SPENT.
WITH US -- FOR THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE I MADE THE DECISION
INTRODUCED AB SEVEN FORTY WHILE
ON A BUS RETURNING FROM PARADISE
CALIFORNIA.
WHERE I SAW FIRSTHAND THE
DESTRUCTION CAUSED BY THE
CAMPFIRE?
I IMMEDIATELY BEGAN WORKING WITH
MY CO AUTHORS ON WHAT WE BELIEVE
TO BE AN APPROPRIATE SOLUTION.
I THANK CREATED SOLELY FOR
VICTIMS NOT UTILITIES.
AS A RESULT OF THE RECENT
WILDFIRES THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
FAMILIES HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES
AND MOST ARE STILL WAITING TO
REGAIN A SENSE OF NORMALCY.
OVER A HUNDRED AND FOUR TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND INSURANCE CLAIMS
TONY TOTALING TWENTY FOUR POINT
EIGHT BILLION WERE FILED IN
RESPONSE TO CALIFORNIA'S TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES.
OUR SPONSOR ABILITIES AS A STATE
TO DEVELOP A SOLUTION TO ADDRESS
THE DESTABILIZING EFFECTS OF
THESE WILDFIRES ON ALL PARTIES
CONTINUES TO GROW ESPECIALLY AS
WE HEAD INTO TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WILDFIRE SEASON.
EXACERBATING THESE HARSH OF IS
THE FACT THAT CATASTROPHIC
RELATED WILDFIRE LAWSUITS CAN
LAST BETWEEN SEVEN TO NINE YEARS.
AND THE CONSTRUCTION DEMAND AND
PRICE SURGES ARE RENDERING
HOMEOWNERS UNDER INSURED BY NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN AFTER ENTIRE
TO COMMUNITIES ARE DESTROYED.
THROUGHOUT VERY STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS AND CONVERSATIONS WITH
OTHER LEGISLATORS IT HAS BECOME
INCREASINGLY CLEAR THAT IN
ADDITION TO THE BURDENS.
SUFFERED BY WILDFIRE VICTIMS
CALIFORNIANS ARE ALSO SUFFERING
TO DEAL WITH INSURANCE ISSUES.
I HAVE HEARD FROM SO MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ABOUT UNDER INSURANCE
AND NON RENEWAL OF AFFECTING
THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
WE ARE WORKING WITH MULTIPLE
ENEMIES INCLUDING FAIR PLAN TO
SEE HOW WE CAN INCREASE ACCESS
AND AFFORDABILITY OF HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE TO ALL AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY THOSE
LIVING.
IN HIGH RISK WILDFIRE AREAS.
IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS THE
NUMBER OF RESIDENTS COVERED BY
FAIR PLAN POLICIES IN THE
WILDLIFE URBAN INTERFACE HAS
GROWN BY 35%.
AND THAT WAS BEFORE THE LAST TO
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN SOME
HIGH RISK COUNTIES THEY'RE
THEY'RE RUNNING 3100% AHEAD OF
THE PREVIOUS YEARS.
AS THIS BILL MOVES THROUGH THE
PROCESS I WILL CONTINUE WORKING
WITH MY COLLEAGUES AND OTHERS TO
EXPLORE HOW WE ADDRESS THESE
INSURANCE CHALLENGES.
A TRUE SOLUTION MUST BE ONE THAT
ENCOURAGES ACCESS TO REASONABLY
PRICED INSURANCE IN HIGH FIRE
RISK AREAS.
CENTERS A. B. SEVEN FORTY
ESTABLISHES A CALIFORNIA
CATASTROPHIC WILD FIRE VICTIMS
FUND AND A COMMISSION TO OVERSEE
IT.
IT'S FUNDED BY A GENERAL FUND
CONTRIBUTION AN EXTENSION OF
EXISTING D. W. R. BOND REPAIR
ASSESSMENTS VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS BY UTILITIES AND
ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS TO THE FUND
BY UTILITIES IF THEY ARE FOUND
TO HAVE CAUSED A WILDFIRE.
THE FIRST DATE CONTRIBUTION WILL
GO DIRECTLY TO THE VICTIMS OF
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES.
ADDITIONALLY AB SEVEN FORTY
INCLUDES A REQUIREMENT THAT A
LEXICAL CONTRA CORPORATIONS MUST
RETAIN A COLLECTIVE SIX POINT
FIVE BILLION IN COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE.
AND INCREASE THEIR DEDUCTIBLE
FROM THE CURRENT LEVEL OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS FUND WILL BE ACCESSED BY
VICTIMS ONLY.
I WILL PROTECT UTILITY RATE
PAYERS FROM INCURRING ADDITIONAL
RATE INCREASES AS A RESULT OF
CONTINUED WILDFIRES.
IT WILL ENSURE THAT VICTIMS OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES INCLUDING
HOMEOWNERS WHO FIND THEMSELVES
UNDER INSURANCE DO THE
CONSTRUCTION DEMAND SURGE
CONCERNS COMPANIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE COMPENSATED IN A
TIMELY MANNER.
VICTIMS OF THE STATE NEED TO MAY
BE MADE WHOLE AND IT SHOULD BE
NOT DONE AS EXPEDITIOUSLY AS
POSSIBLE.
ALL WHILE HOLDING UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE AND NOT AT THE
EXPENSE OF REPAIRS.
I KNOW THEY'RE STILL MANY
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
HAD AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU AS WE
CONTINUE THIS WORK.
THE GOAL FIRST AND FOREMOST OF
ANY WILDFIRE FUND SHOULD SHOULD
BE TO PROTECT ALL CURRENT AND
FIX FUTURE VICTIMS.
STABLING UTILITIES SHOULD BE A
BY PRODUCT OF WHATEVER WE DO NOT
THE FOCUS.
I BELIEVE IF WE CONSIDER ALL
OPTIONS THROUGH THAT LENS WILL
ARRIVE AT A SOLUTION THAT WE CAN
ALL STAND BEHIND.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ACOSTA
NIGHT OF THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE
THAT WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THE NO INTEREST ANYONE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
MR MORE LUCK THE MOTHER MISTER
ARCHULETA.
SOON BURKE I'M REALLY -- REALLY
PLEASED TO SEE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU I I I SIDE JUST A
FEW QUESTIONS BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
YOU'VE GOT YOUR BILL AND NOW
WE'VE GOT SOMETHING THAT CAME
OUT FRIDAY AND WE GOT EVERYBODY.
GOT THE COURT CAME OUT WITH
SOMETHING YESTERDAY AND SO MAYBE
JUST TO HAVE SOME DISCUSSION.
I SERVED ON THE BUDGET
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE I DIDN'T
SEE ONE DOLLAR.
OR OR OR ONE DOLLAR DAHLE TO SET
UP A FUND OR VICTIMS FOUNDER OR
OR EVEN ALLOCATE OR DEDICATE
WHO'S WHO IT'S GOING TO BE -- SO
YOURS YOU'RE REQUESTING FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION.
RIGHT FROM THE BUDGET.
ODD WHICH WHICH IS A BOLD MOVE
SO COULD YOU EXPLAIN THAT AND
WHY DON'T WE SEE IT IN THE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- I CAN'T
EXPLAIN WHY WE DON'T SEE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BECAUSE I
THINK -- I I CAN'T EXPLAIN WHY
WE DON'T SEE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BUT I CAN TELL YOU IS IT
YES IT IS A BOLD MOVE BUT WE DO
HAVE CURRENT WILD FIRE VICTIMS
AND THE STATE DOES HOLD SOME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT.
AND I EIGHT BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING SHOULD BE THAT WE
SHOULD TAKE SOME RESPONSIBILITY
AND I THINK THE 200-017-2000
EIGHTEEN WHILE FIRE VICTIMS
DESERVE THAT -- AND SO FOR ME
THAT WAS A AN ALLOCATION THAT I
BELIEVED WAS.
A SHO OF OUR SOME OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITY.
OF THE STATE WANTS TO USE MORE
ELECTRICITY YOU KNOW WE WANT TO
CHARGE CARS AND TRUCKS AND AND
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO HELP
UTILITIES TO BUILD THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE SO I THINK THAT'S
A GOOD MOVE IN KIND OF KIND OF
ART.
THANKS FOR BROACHING THANK YOU --
THE SECOND WAS A SURCHARGE ON
RATE PAYERS.
THAT CONCLUDES.
IN TWENTY TWENTY SO COULD YOU
EXPLAIN.
SO MY VIEW WAS -- I DIDN'T
WANTED AND TO INCREASE --
OBVIOUSLY A VERY SENSITIVE I
COME FROM A LOW INCOME COMMUNITY
AND SO OBVIOUSLY MY INTENTION
WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DIDN'T
SEE AN INCREASE AND REPAIR --
BILLS HOWEVER WE HAVE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME LOOKING AND TALKING
TO THE COMMERCIAL REPAIRS AS
WELL BECAUSE D. W. R. FEES WERE
WERE CREATED AS A RESULT OF THE
ENERGY CRISIS AND SO -- WE'RE
NOT WE DON'T ACTUALLY OUR GROUP
OF CO AUTHORS BELIEVES THAT --
THAT THEY DON'T HOLD THE SAME
WAY BUT YET THEY STILL DO USE --
LIKE TRICITY AND SO AS WE LOOK
AT USING D. W. R. FUNDS AS WE
ARE LOOKING THROUGH THE LENS AND
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
HAVE THE CONVERSATION OF WHAT
PROPORTION OF THAT WE WOULD
REDUCE FOR COMING COMMERCIAL
RATE PAYERS BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
DIFFERENT.
LEVEL OF RESPONSIBILITY HERE WE
ALL HAVE RESPONSIBILITY BUT THEY
HAVE A LITTLE DIFFERENT
RESPONSIBILITY THAN THEY DID IN
THE ORIGINAL D. W. R. FEES.
IN THE LAST TWO QUESTIONS ONE IS --
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS -- IS
THAT REALISTIC AND THEN -- TO
CAN YOU COMMENT ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE FEDERAL
BANKRUPTCY COURT.
AND HOW COULD THIS BILL HELPS.
THOSE EFFORTS -- SO I WOULD SAY
THE THE VOLUNTARY YES I DO THINK
IT'S POSSIBLE I THINK WITH THE
COMPLETE PACKAGE I THINK THAT
THE I'LL USE AND THE PO USE WILL
SEE THE BENEFIT OF PARTICIPATING
IN A FUND AND SO -- I THINK THAT
THE GOAL IS TO USE A CARROT AND
A STICK AT FIRST OF THAT SO WILL
WE WE CAN DO IT.
A AND SO AS OF AT THIS TIME I
HAVEN'T GOTTEN A LOT OF PUSH
BACK ON THE CONTRIBUTION.
FROM THE I'LL USE OR THE PO USE --
HOW DOES THIS HELP WITH THE --
WITH THE BANKRUPTCY.
I DON'T HAVE AN ACTUAL ANSWER
FOR THAT I DO KNOW OBVIOUSLY
THERE ARE THOSE WHO HAVE PUT IN
WHO HAVE FILED WITH THE
BANKRUPTCY COURT THAT SUPPORT OF
FUND -- AND ARE WILLING TO
PARTICIPATE ON THE BEHALF OF P.
JEANNIE FOR THAT PLAN -- AND SO
I THINK THAT'S KIND OF A MOVE IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND IT SHOWS THAT A FUND IS
NEEDED AND THAT THOSE WHO ARE --
TO PARTICIPATE IN P. JEANNIE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THEY DO
HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
RESPONSIBILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
WHAT THAT FUND LOOKS LIKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VENTURE THANK YOU MISTER
ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU FOR BRITTANY'S BUILDINGS
EXCELLENT EXCITED THAT IT'S HERE
AND WE'RE FINALLY DOING
SOMETHING. FOR SO MANY
HOMEOWNERS IN AND THE STATE A
CALIFORNIA.
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IMAGINE
THE MECHANISM WILL WILL
REIMBURSE -- THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES ARE HOMEOWNERS AND AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH THE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
AND YOU MENTION FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AT WHAT POINT.
IS IT CLASSIFIED FOR
REIMBURSEMENT.
SO RIGHT NOW WE HAVEN'T DEFINED
WHAT CATASTROPHIC MEANS AND THE
BILL YET -- AND WE'VE DONE THAT
ON PURPOSE BECAUSE AS THE BILL
CONTINUES TO MOVE AND CHANGE OUT
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE WILL MOVING
CHANGE WE DO ASK THAT THE
INSURANCE THAT THE UTILITIES DO
TAKE UP MORE INSURANCE.
AND THAT THEY ARE -- MORE CORING
MORE THAN THAN TRADITIONAL TEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF DEDUCTIBLE WE
RAISE THAT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
WE BELIEVE THAT IF WE RAISE THE
INSURANCE TO WHAT IS POSSIBLE IN
THE MARKET AND TO BUY IT ON
DESPITE SIZE OF THE SIZE OF THE
MARKET OF EACH UTILITY.
WHAT QUALIFIES FOR CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE WILL BE ADJUSTED FOR
SOMEONE WHO HAS 10% OF THE
FOR WILDFIRE IS DIFFERENT THAN
SOMEONE LIKE A P. JEANNIE WHO
HAS A LARGER PERCENTAGE OF THE
MARKET AND SO WE'RE STILL
WORKING? TO DEFEAT USE I REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN WE
DEFINE WHAT CATASTROPHIC IS THAT
IT IS.
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE -- IT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
SLAP I DON'T BELIEVE WILL BE
ABLE TO SLAP A ONE NUMBER ON A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE I DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING
TO BE APPROPRIATE.
IT COULD BE THE SIZE OF THE FIRE
THE THE NUMBER OF BUILDINGS IN
THE AND THE THE LOSS AND THE
MARKET SHARE OF THAT UTILITY.
THERE YOU GO OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
START.
THANK YOU IN.
AND THANK YOU AS SOMEONE THAT I
I APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS SITE JOIN IN THAT TOUR
PARADISE I THINK WE ALSO OFFER
CELLS WHAT A HORRIBLE.
SITUATION IT IS IN THE FACT THAT
THIS BILL COMES OUT OF YOUR
CONCERN AND COMPASSION FOR THE
VICTIMS IS THE RIGHT PLACE TO BE
LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE AND AT
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS THAT ARE RAISED HERE
AND I I KNOW THAT THIS IS.
A YOU THE KNOWLEDGE A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND I KNOW WITH THAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THEY WANT TO
BE IN THIS -- IT SOMEWHERE IN
THIS SPACE AND SO I DO HAVE
QUESTIONS AND THEIR SUBSTANTIAL
QUESTIONS BUT I AND I APPRECIATE
THAT WE WANT TO MOVE THE BILL
FORD I GUESS IT JUST.
GIVES ME SOME PAUSE THAT WE
SHOULD.
TAKE THE TIME FOR SOME OF THESE
THAT YOU MAY OR MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO ANSWER TODAY BUT CERTAINLY
THE I'VE.
THE WHOLE VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION
LIMIT FROM UTILITIES AND
NOBODY'S COME HERE TO TESTIFY
FOR THE UTILITIES.
SO IF THEY'RE HAPPY ARE NOT
HAPPY THEY'RE NOT REALLY SAYING
ANYTHING WELL WE KNOW THE LET'S
SAY A LOT WHEN THEY'RE NOT HAPPY
DON'T THEY THAT IS TRUE.
BUT MAYBE -- YOU KNOW THERE IS A
QUESTION ABOUT WHY YOU'RE
LIMITING YOU KNOW THE THE
DAMAGES THAT HAVE BEEN COSTS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN WHAT I
THINK YOU'RE TRYING TO RAISE IN
THIS BILL.
YOU'RE ONLY ASKING UTILITIES TO
COME UP WITH A FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR TOTAL IS THAT RIGHT RIGHT
BUT IT'SNOT BECAUSE THAT'S THE
TOTAL AMOUNT WE BELIEVE THE FUND
WILL NEED -- WE ALSO CAN BOND ON
THE FINDING WITH BETWEEN D. W.
R. FEES AND THE UTILITIES
CONTRIBUTION WITH BONDS AND
INSURANCE WE BELIEVE WE CAN GET
THAT THAT THE FUND WOULD REACH
ABOUT A TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR MARK.
BUT PART OF WHAT WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO I KNOW THIS ISN'T THE
FISCAL CONNECTICUT OKAY SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT PART OF WHAT
YOU'RE.
TRYING TO DO IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S AN A PORTION THAT
ARE WE'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THAT A PORTION AND AND AND
WHETHER OR NOT -- THOSE WHO ARE
REALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PROBLEM ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
STEPPING UP RIGHT ABSOLUTELY AND
SO -- OBVIOUSLY THE THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR.
ANNUAL CONTRIBUTION FROM THE
STATE IS A VERY GENEROUS THING --
BUT IT DOES RAISE THE QUESTION
AS TO WHETHER WE WE SHOULD BE
PAYING VERSES THE UTILITY SHOULD
BE PAYING WHO HAVE BEEN FOUND AT
FAULT RIGHT AND I WOULD AGREE
WITH YOU AND I THINK WHEN WE
FIRST STARTED WORKING ON THIS
BILL WE ACTUALLY WERE HOPING TO
COVER BOTH -- UTILITY BECAUSE
WILDFIRES AND NON UTILITY
BECAUSE WHILE BUYERS AND WE FELT
THAT WE WERE ORIGINALLY DOING
THE ONGOING CONTRIBUTION FOR
THOSE THAT WERE NOT UTILITY
BECAUSE WHILE BUYERS AS WE'VE
HAD THE CONVERSATION WE'RE
STARTING TO BELIEVE THAT IT MAY
BE.
MORE REALISTIC TO ONLY DO IT
UTILITY BECAUSE WILD FIRES AND
SO WE ARE LOOKING AT AND I WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU AND SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT WHAT THAT ONGOING IF
WE CONTINUE THAT ON GOING.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN WRITTEN --
FOR FOR NINE UTILITY COSTS WHILE
THEY'RE BOTH ORIGINALLY WE WROTE
THE BILL FOR BOTH SO IT WAS FOR
UTILITY AND NON UTILITY BECAUSE
WILDFIRE AND THE PORTION FOR
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA WAS CAN
CUT.
CONTRIBUTING WAS BECAUSE NOT ALL
ONLY 10% OF WILDFIRES OF THESE
LARGE WHY FIVE CAST OF
WILDFLOWERS ARE CAUSED BY
UTILITIES.
AND SO IF IT WERE GOING TO BE.
FOR NINE UTILITY BECAUSE
WILDFIRES OBVIOUSLY WE CAN ASK
UTILITIES TO PAY THE BURDEN FOR
NON UTILITY BECAUSE WILD FIRES
AND SO.
THAT'S WHEN WE ORIGINALLY HAD
DISCUSSED THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION ON GOING I THINK SINCE
THEN WE HAVE STARTED HOW THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHETHER WE
WILL MAKE AND THAT WE ARE
CONSIDERING AN ADJUSTMENT TO
THAT BECAUSE I DO AGREE THAT
THAT IS A LARGE.
ON GOING CONTRIBUTION.
RIGHT BUT AS I UNDERSTAND YOUR
BILL THIS IS A SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WILD FIRE VICTIMS BUILT
RIGHT NOW THIS IS A CURRENT AN
ON GOING WILD FIRE VICTIMS FUND.
THIS IS NOT MEANT TO PAVE
ACTIVITY AT JUST THE FIRST AND
TING SO JUST THE FIRST FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WILL GO
TO SUBSIDIZE THE SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN VICTIMS IT IS AN
ONGOING VICTIMS WILDFIRE FIND.
RIGHT OKAY WHICH IS WHY WE USE
D. W. R. FEES THAT'S AN ON GOING
ON GOING CONTRIBUTION IS THAT D.
W. OUR FEES ARE ONGOING
CONTRIBUTIONS.
AND THE MONEY FROM THE UTILITIES
IS FOR TO BUILD A FIND THAT WE
WOULD THEN BOND OR AND AND SURE
ON OR AT LEAST AS IT RELATES.
TO THIS BILL AT SOME LEVEL IS
HIS TRYING TO COMPENSATE.
RIGHTLY SO FOR THE VICTIMS IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY RIGHT.
A PORTION OR SHOULD HAVE IT BUT
YOUR YOUR AND YOUR IDENTIFYING
THE FIRST FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FROM THE STATE FOR THAT PURPOSE.
IS THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING THAT UTILITIES
VOLUNTARILY PUT IN IS IS THAT
FOR THAT PURPOSE ARE NOW THAT IS
FOR THE ON GOING NO BECAUSE THAT
IS NOT ALL OF THE UTILITIES
RESPONSIBILITY RIGHT.
THOSE THOSE THOSE FIRES HOW WILL
FIND A CAUSE AND SOME HAVE FOUND
A BECAUSE ALREADY IN SUMMER P.
JEANNIE BECAUSE IN OTHER FIRES
WE HAVE FOUND THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
UTILITY BECAUSE OF THAT.
UTILITY TO LADY CONTRIBUTION IS
FOR ONGOING FIRES SO THAT WE
BILL DEFINED ONE LARGE FIND THAT
IS HAS THE CAPACITY TO FIND ON
AND HAVE A CONSISTENT INCOME AND
THAT IS LARGE ENOUGH TO REACH
THAT TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLAR.
MARKET WITHOUT CONTINUING TO
RAISE RATES ON REPAIRS SO YES
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION.
YES THAT PART WE HAVE ALLOCATED
IN AFTER SPEAKING WITH THE
VICTIM'S GROUPS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT IT WAS A SUGGESTION FROM
THEM THAT THEY FELT STRONGLY
THAT THAT WOULD.
THAT THEY WERE HAPPY TO SEE.
SOME SORT OF ALLOCATION TO HELP
THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE FACING
BECAUSE OF CERTAIN THINGS LIKE
P. JEANNIE AND AND BEING A
BANKRUPTCY THAT THEY'RE FACING
SOME CHALLENGE THAT
TRADITIONALLY OF VICTIMS GROUP
WOULD NOT FACE.
AMEND THAT PHILIP FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS JUST TO HELP
OFFSET A PORTION OF THEM.
OKAY THAT THAT'S CLEAR TO ME
OKAY ON A PHILOSOPHICAL LEVEL I
AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO GOING FORWARD.
WITH A CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE
RELIEF FUND WITH VARIOUS
COMPONENTS.
BUT GOING BACKWARDS OBVIOUSLY
IT'S A GREAT THING TO DO AND I
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU WOULD WANT TO
DO IT.
IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME THAN IF THE
UTILITIES ARE AT FAULT. FOR
THOSE FIRES AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN DOES THE GENERAL FUND
GET PAID BACK FOR THAT MONEY --
I CAN SEE A POTENTIAL OF IN
GENERAL FINE BEING PAID BACK FOR
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE NOT GONE INTO
THE DEEP DISCUSSIONS ON THAT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION I THINK
THAT WAS FROM A RECENT
STAKEHOLDER MEETING THAT WE HAD
WHERE.
WE HAD WE HAD WITH THE REPAIRS
THAT WE HAD DECIDED TO MOVE
FORWARD ON MOVING THAT.
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION TO OKAY
WELL AT LEAST THE ONE PERSON'S
PERSPECTIVE WOULD BE WE WOULD
HELP THAT -- THE STATE WOULD BE
A YOU KNOW THAT WOULD THAT AND
THE VERY IDEA STATE OBLIGATION.
AT FOR THE USE THAT THE UTILITY
ILLEGALITY BECAUSE WILDFIRE
ARSON AND I CAN APPRECIATE THAT
AND I I TAKE THAT NO SERIOUSLY
[inaudible]
OKAY -- AND AND SO THIS THIS
PROPSAL WOULD BE GOOD IF.
THERE'S TWO QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
WHAT THE RATE PAYERS PAY I GET
IT IS ABOUT THIRTY DOLLARS A
MONTH A THIRTY DOLLARS A YEAR
RIGHT.
THAT'S THE COST OF THIS BILL
WOULD -- ADVANCE OVER THE COURSE
OF THE NEXT TEN OR TWENTY YEARS
TO BUILD THIS WILDLIFE WILDFIRE
A PORTION OF THE FINE.
GUY BUT THAT'S WHAT THE IT
PEOPLE SAID HOW MUCH DOES THIS
COST PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT AND
YOUR DISTRICT IT'S IT'S THE SAME
APPROXIMATELY AND LESSER LOW
INCOME UNLESS YOU'RE A LOW
INCOME -- PARTICIPATE IN IT.
OF ANY OF THE UTILITIES OKAY AND
AND THEN TO THE QUESTION THAT
PEOPLE ASK US ALL THE TIME --
ARE WE REALLY HOLDING.
P. JEANNIE TO ACCOUNT.
FOR THE PROBLEMS THAT THEY
CAUSED AND THE OBLIGATIONS THEY
HAVE GOING BACKWARDS AND
FORWARDS WHAT WOULD YOU SAYTO
THEM I WOULD SAY A 100% I WOULD
SAY THAT.
WELL LIKE I SAID WHEN WE'VE BEEN
TALKING TO THOSE WHO ARE GOING
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE FUND THE
LARGEST FUND PORTION OF THE FUND
WILL COME FROM A P. JEANNIE
WOULD COME FROM P. GINNY BECAUSE
THEY CARRY THE LARGEST MARKET
SHARE -- I AM ALL TOO AWARE --
LIKE I SAID AFTER BEING TO
PARADISE AND TO BEING SOME OF
THESE OTHER FIRES THAT YOU THAT
P. JEANNIE HOLD RESPONSIBILITY
AND ANY UTILITY.
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE SHOULD HOLD
THE RESPONSIBILITY HOWEVER WE
HAVE CREATED A SYSTEM IN WHICH
VICTIMS ARE HOLDING THE
RESPONSIBILITY RIGHT NOW AND I
DO NOT THINK THAT THAT SHOULD BE
ACCEPTABLE TO US.
WE CREATED THE SYSTEM NOT THE
VICTIMS AND ME MAY NOT HAVE ALL
BEEN HERE WHEN THE SYSTEM WAS
CREATED BUT WE'RE HERE NOW AND
THERE'S A PROBLEM.
AND VICTIMS ARE SUFFERING FROM
IT.
AND WHILE P. JEANNIE ITSELF
FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY AND ALL
THEIR PROTECTING THEMSELVES WE
HAVE TO PROTECT THE VICTIMS AND
SO WE CAN HAVE THAT ARGUMENT AND
ABSOLUTELY P. JEANNIE AT THE END
OF THE DAY ANY I OWE YOU.
THAT IS AT FAULT FOR A WHILE
FIRE THAT BURNS DOWN VICTIMS
HOMES OR BURNS DOWN A COMMUNITY
SHOULD BE A 100% HELD
RESPONSIBLE AND THIS THIS FUND
DOES NOT CHANGE THAT.
BUT WHAT THIS ONE DOES IS PUTS
VICTIMS FIRST AND AS AS WERE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
OUR OBLIGATION NOT TO REQUIRE
THAT.
COMMUNITIES WAIT SEVEN TO NINE
YEARS TO SEE THAT KIND OF
RECOVERY BUT THAT THING GET
THEIR HOMES REBUILT NOW.
THAT WHEN ENTIRE COMMUNITIES ARE
BURNT DOWN AND BECAUSE OF NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN THERE IS A
PRICE SURGE AND THEY CAN NOT
REBUILD THEIR HOMES THAT WE HAVE
CREATED SOME SORT OF SAFETY NET
FOR THEM.
THIS IS OUR RESPOND THERE ARE
PORTIONS OF THIS THAT ARE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY YES THERE ARE I
OWE YOU RESPONSIBILITIES
ABSOLUTELY AND MAYBE ONE DAY
APPEAL YOU RESPONSIBILITY.
BUT WE HAVE RESPONSIBILITY TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE TAKNG CARE OF
FIRST AND FOREMOST AND THAT'S
WHERE THIS BILL COMES FROM AND
THAT'S THE ITENTION.
SO THAT WOULD BE MY ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION IN JUST A FISH.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME.
AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES ME.
SO MOTIVATED TO KEEP YOUR BILL
MOVING IS BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE
DOING IT IT OF WITH THE FOR THE
RIGHT REASONS.
AND WHILE I THINK THAT THERE ARE
A LOT OF SIGNIFICANT ISSUES THAT
ARE RAISED IN YOUR BILL.
THAT REALLY HAVEN'T BEEN TALKED
OUT OR THOUGHT OUT COMPLETELY --
THAT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
FROM A PHILOSOPHICAL POINT OF
VIEW. TO INDICATE HOW MUCH WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE VICTIMS
THIS IS THE UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THIS COMMITTEE
IS INSURANCE AND WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S ADEQUATE INSURANCE AND
WE'VE HAD HEARINGS ON THIS TO
TRY TO UNDERSTAND.
THE PROBLEMS OF FIVE THE UNDER
INSURED NOT JUST THE NO
INSURANCE BUT THE UNDERINSURED
AND WE CERTAINLY SAW THAT WITH
THESE WILD FIRES AT A LOT OF
LEVELS -- AND I DON'T KNOW IF
WE'VE HEARD A NEW UPDATE ABOUT
THE FAIR.
PLAN AND WHETHER THAT'S REALLY
BEING TAPPED TO DO IN A
SIGNIFICANT WAY TO KNOW WHETHER
THE HOMEOWNERS MARKETS CAVING OR
NOT BUT I KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN
HEARINGS ON THAT AND IT'S
ANOTHER IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
JURISDICTION HERE.
THAT WOULD BE MY HOPE THAT --
THROUGH THE CHAIRS LEADERSHIP
THAT AS THIS STUFF GETS MORE
FINALIZING CRYSTALLIZE THAT --
THAT YOU CAN SEE WHETHER OR NOT
WE MIGHT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A MORE FURTHER EXAMINATION
OF WHATEVER IS THE ADORATION OF
THIS PROPOSAL FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN OR OTHER OTHERS IS BECAUSE
FOR AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND KILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MISTER JOHNS.
AND JUST TO THAT ROAD THROUGH
THE CHAIR I JUST WELL YOU KNOW --
I THINK OUR OFFICE IN OUR STAFF
OF ALWAYS BEEN VERY VERY GOOD
ESPECIALLY WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE AND AND WITH THIS
CHAIR TO MAKING SURE THAT
WHATEVER WE WORK ON AND WHATEVER
WE WORKED ON OVER THE YEARS AS A
PASTOR COMMITTEES THAT WE STAY
IN TOUCH WITH THE COMMITTEE. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT EVERYTHING
THAT COMES THROUGH IS STILL IS
STILL IN LINE WITH THE GOALS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES.
I THINK I'M SURE IN AND ACTUALLY --
SENATOR ACTUALLY CONSIDER GLAZER
KIND OF PICKED UP ON MY CONCERN
WITH THE BILL SPECIFICALLY.
THINK I'M GRASPING ALL THE
CONCEPTS BEHIND IT BUT YOU DO
HAVE SOME -- BLANK LINES IN THE
ACTUAL LANGUAGE OF THE BILL AND
WHICH WHICH WHILE I'VE SUPPORT
INTENT IN THE AND THE HIGH LEVEL
CONVERSATION -- THAT YOU AND MR
GLAZER JUST HAD -- IN A LOOKING
AT THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL CAN
USE YOU'VE GOT SOME.
DOLLAR AMOUNTS THAT ARE LEFT.
UNFILLED -- WHICH IS NOT AS BIG
A CONCERN FOR ME HIS SINCE IT
SAYS THIS INTENT LANGUAGE BUT
YOU DO HAVE SOME SPECIFIC
DEFINITIONS THAT.
ARE LEFT -- UNDEFINED -- AS
BLANK LINES IN ACTUAL LANGUAGE
OF THE BILL -- WHICH GIVES ME
SOME PAUSE.
IF YOU WANT.
EXPLAIN MATTER I MEAN I KNOW YOU
HAVE TO HAVE SOME LYING I I MEAN
I HAD THE BEST EXPLANATION GIVEN
THINK IS THE ONE THAT I'VE
ALREADY GIVEN WHICH WERE IN
PROCESS OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE -- CAREFUL
AND PROPERLY ANALYZED THE
DIFFERENCE OF MARKET SHARE AND
SO THAT WE DON'T JUST PLUG IN
NUMBERS BECAUSE THIS BODY HAS
BEEN KNOWN TO PLUG JUST PLUG IN
SOME NUMBERS -- WE WANT TO BE
MUCH MORE -- THOUGHTFUL AND
CAREFUL ABOUT THAT AND MUCH MORE
ANALYTICAL AND DATA DRIVEN WHEN
WE PLUG IN THOSE NUMBERS AND
THAT THEY ARE BASED ON MARKET
SHARE AND RISK AND THINGS LIKE
THAT AND NOT JUST NUMBERS THAT
WE JUST MADE UP BASED ON
CONTRACTS OR NUMBERS IN THE
DEFINITIONS WHEN DO.
YOU THINK THAT YOU'LL HAVE THOSE
FINALLY WE'RE WORKING ON THEM
NOW SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND WITH THE
NEXT. TO COMMITTEES.
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE THE THE
APPROPRIATE AND CORRECT NUMBERS
I THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
AS THIS IS -- YEAH I'M I'M JUST
AS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DEFINITIONS AS I AM THAT I CAN
APPRECIATE THAT YEAH -- YOU KNOW
TO TYPICALLY HAVE A KNOWING
THESE TYPES OF SITUATIONS BUT
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'VE GOT A
COUPLE MORE COMMITTEES TO GO.
TO I'M USING A LAYOFF TODAY AND
AND THEN HOPE THAT YOU GET A
GOOD FINAL PRODUCT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
SENATOR WASN'T.
JUST GENERALLY I JUST WANTED A
JOIN IN THE CHORUS ON TALK ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS BUILDING
WHY WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD AND
ALTHOUGH.
WE HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO AMEND OUR
BUDGET AND APPROVE FUNDING FOR
EMERGENCIES LIKE WOULDN'T -- THE
OROVILLE DAM.
BUSTED AND WE HAVE FLOODING ALL
OVER AN ANCHOR LOOTING.
FUTURE PASS FIREMAN'S WE WERE AB
ACTUALLY ABLE.
TO APPROVE US SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
FROM OUR BUDGET LATER IN THE
YEAR AFTER THE BUDGET HAVE BEEN
APPROVED.
ALTHOUGH WE'VE DONE THAT I DON'T
I DON'T NECESSARILY THINK
THAT'LL HAPPEN WITH THIS BILL I
DON'T SEE US USING.
GENERAL FUND OR STATE MONEY AND
AND THE FINAL SOLUTION OUT I
LEASE AYE AYE THAT THINK WE CAN
FIND OTHER WAYS OTHER MECHANISMS
THAT DON'T.
PUT A TAXPAYERS ON THE HOOK FOR
THIS BUT I APPRECIATE THIS
CONVERSATION.
AND IF YOU ASK THE FOURTH AVENUE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION.
I THINK YOU FIGURED IT OUT.
AND THAT'S THE SUPPORTER AND
THIRD AVENUE HAS A WAIT AND
MAYBE BECAUSE FOURTH AVENUE IS
CLOSER TO THE FIRES OKAY I GUESS
SO.
BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND I JUST WANNA.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING ON THIS IS
A VERY DIFFICULT ISSUE HIGHLY
TECHNICAL BUT WE DO NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS BECAUSEOF
COURSE WE HAVE THE VICTIMS.
THERE ARE ARE OUT THERE -- AND
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE AND ONE
SOMETHING HAPPENS WE HAVE TO BE
PREPARED.
AND AND WE ARE RIGHT NOW BALANCE
SEEN ON THE VERGE OF POTENTIALLY
SEEN.
OUR OTHER OF A UTILITIES
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE TO GET
ACCESS -- TO TO WORKING CAPITAL
STAY IN BUSINESS AND THAT'S A
BIG PROBLEM FACING OUR STATE AND
I I AND I THINK THIS IS THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM FACING OUR STATE
TODAY.
N. F. -- IT IF WE WERE DOING OUR
JOBS HERE IN THIS LEGISLATURE WE
WOULD DEDICATE EVERY.
MINUTE OF THE DAY EVERY MOMENT
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
AND ENSURE THAT WE WE DO IT
PRIOR TO FIRE SEASON SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITHIN THE
NEXT MANY [inaudible]
SENATOR BURGESS [inaudible]
SENATOR BRIDGES.
IF YOU'RE A WOMAN I JUST WANT TO
DO A COMMAND -- THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY WOMAN -- BURKE I THINK
THIS.
THIS IS A HEADY ISSUE IT'S
COMPLICATED IT HAS.
EXTRAORDINARY POLITICAL FORCE IN
DYNAMICS.
BUT ONE THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT WE GRAPPLE WITH SO
I THINK -- I'M DEFINITELY
IMPRESSED THAT YOU'VE TAKEN SUCH
A STRONG STEP AT THIS AND THAT
WILL PROBABLY GO THROUGH A
NUMBER OF ITERATIONS.
MUCH OF WHICH WILL BE
SUBSTANTIVE I SUSPECT OVER THE
COMING PERIOD OF TIME -- I'D
LIKE TO SEE YOU KNOW HOW THAT
PLAYS OUT BUT I KNOW IN THE
ASSEMBLY THIS IS THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN.
THAT IS ODD -- BILL AND I
SUSPECT THAT AS IT GOES THROUGH
ITS EVOLUTIONS IT WILL ACHIEVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT -- ON THE
SENATE SIDE AS WELL I'D LIKE TO
SEE SOME OF THE FINE TUNING --
LIKE EVERY.
EDUCATED BUYER WANTS TO WRITE
WHAT.
SELLS INTO BUT CONGRATULATIONS
ON TAKING SUCH A STRONG STEP AT
THIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU -- WILL ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK -- BEFORE I
MOVE ON TO THE TO THE MOTION I
JUST WANT EVERYONE TO AND I
WANTED TO SHARE THAT IT IS A
VERY COMPLICATED ISSUE AND TO
THE CREDIT OF THE AUTHOR HER AND
I SPENT.
MANY NIGHTS SPEAKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE ADDRESSING SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS AND DOWN.
THE REALITY IS THAT WHEN IT
INITIALLY CAME TO US AND WE WERE
DISCUSSING THE FOR PAN RIGHT OUT
CREDITS AT AND IT DIDN'T MAKE IT
INTO THIS BILL BUT BECAUSE OF
THAT IT'S HERE BUT THE BIGGEST
PORTION THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED IS GONNA BE IN OUR
SENATE UTILITIES.
AND DODD GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
ADDRESS OF FISCAL IMPACTS AND SO
I APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S COMMENTS
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS.
I'M ALSO IN THE SENATE ENERGY.
COMMITTEE SO WE WILL CIRCLE BACK
AND ENSURE THAT ALL OF YOU GUYS
HAVE THE PROPER INFORMATION AS
IT MOVES -- FORWARD STILL THANK
YOU OUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RIGHT NOW I AND I I KNOW IT'S A
COMPLICATED ISSUE -- I KNOW IT'S
A CHALLENGING ISSUE BOTH MORALLY
AND POLITICALLY AND I I
APPRECIATE THOSE WHO HAVE SPOKEN
TODAY AND YOUR QUESTIONS AND
YOUR COMMENTS AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
SENATORS WERE IN THREE
COMMITTEES WERE LOOKING FOR AND
TO WORKING ON WITH CENTER TO
HUESO IN.
THE NEXT COMMITTEE -- I JUST DO
BELIEVE THAT THE FACE OF THIS
ISSUE NEEDS TO BE VICTIMS.
AND AS I SAID IN MY OPENING
REMARKS AND A BY PRODUCT BE.
THE STABILIZATION OF UTILITIES
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT AS LONG AS
WE KEEP OUR EYE ON THAT BALL
THAT WE WILL ALL FIND SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN AGREE ON WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER TO LANA PLEASE COME
AROUND TO PASS THE SENATE ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATION
COMMITTEE RUBIO.
HI RUBIO AYE JONES.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I BATES
[inaudible]
BOARD YES.
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER GLAZER AYE HUESO.
HUESO I MITCHELL MORLOCK MORE
LIKE I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A BOTH WERE
GONNA HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR THE
REST OF THE MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
OUR NEXT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO A. B. -- TWELVE TWENTY THREE
MR ARAMBULA IS HE OKAY -- HE I
DON'T SEE HIM CRAZY HERE SO I'M
GONNA MOVE ON TO AB.
TWO NINETY FIVE AS TO DALY
WELCOME THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
GREETINGS MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- FIRST LET ME SAY ALL
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
AS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
REFERENCED ON PAGE THREE IN THE
ANALYSIS.
THIS BILL CHANGES THE FORMULA
THAT DETERMINES THE MINIMUM
NECESSARY WORKING CAPITAL. FOR
UNDER WRITTEN TITLE COMPANIES.
THE BILL IS NEEDED BECAUSE AN
ACCOUNTING STANDARD ADOPTED
RECENTLY BY THE FINANCIAL
ACCOUNTING STANDARDS BOARD WILL
HAVE NEGATIVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR TITLE COMPANIES.
THIS NEW STANDARD COULD RESULT
IN INCREASED COSTS FOR ESCROW IS
FOR REAL PROPERTY TRANSACTIONS
INCLUDING.
HOME PURCHASES.
JOHN NOR WOULD ON BEHALF OF
FIRST AMERICAN TITLE INSURANCE
COMPANY AND JOHN CALDWELL ON
BEHALF OF THE LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION.
ARE HERE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND I SEE.
THE GENTLEMAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION AS WELL MISTER CRAIG
PAGE HERE WITH US -- IS ABNORMAL
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT GO
AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CRAIG PAGE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE SOLUTION
WE REPRESENT -- TITLE INSURERS
AN INTERIM TITLE COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO THE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL WERE STRONG SUPPORT
OF I THINK THE AUTHORS LAID OUT.
PARTICULARLY THE THE REASONS WHY
THE BILL IS NECESSARY AND ALSO
IF YOU LOOK AT THE THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES IT WAS ALSO VERY WELL
WRITTEN AND LAYS OUT A THE
ISSUES AS TO WHY WE'RE HERE AND
AND SEEKING THE BILL TODAY.
A IT'S VERY BORROWED VERY
NARROWLY DRAFTED BILL.
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT OF
AMENDMENTS -- AS SPONSORED THAT --
OR IN THE IN THE ANALYSIS AS
WELL THE BUMPING UP OF THE
TWENTY OF THE WORKING CAPITAL
AMOUNTS FROM 1-000-022-5000.
AND ALSO THE LIMITING THE LEASE
EXEMPTION TO OPERATING LEASES
ONLY.
I HAVE WITH ME AND AN EXPERT
FROM THE INDUSTRY.
RANDY BRADLEY WHOSE EGGS X. --
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
MOTHER LOCAL MOTHER LODE HOLDING
COMPANY AND PLASTER TITLE HERE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL AS
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND TURNED -- MEMBERS
JOHN NOR WOULD ON BEHALF OF
FIRST AMERICAN FINANCIAL%
CORPORATION.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE BILL
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT YOU MAY COME
UP TO THE MIKE.
ANYBODY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE.
COME UP TO THE MIKE.
THE NO INTEREST A MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS MR MORLOCK.
THIS IS A RATHER NEW COMPLEX
AREA AND FOR ACCOUNTANTS AS LIKE
40% OF COMPANIES IN THE COUNTRY
ARE STILL TRYING TO GET THEIR
HANDS AROUND THIS NEW --
PROPAGATION -- SO IT'S COMPLEX
IN AND GAS BE THE GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTING STANDARDS BOARD IS
GOING TO BE NEXT SO IT'S GONNA
BE REAL INTERESTING TO SEE OUT.
GOVERNMENT REACTS TO HAVING --
TO INPUT THEIR LEASES ON ON
THEIR BOOKS OR WE'RE GOING TO
SEE SOME AMAZING FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS AS IF THEY'RE NOT BAD
ENOUGH RIGHT NOW -- IN
GOVERNMENT LAND -- BUT I'M JUST
WONDERING -- CINNAMON DAILY --
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU NEED A CO
AUTHOR CAN AHEAD IF YOU MAKE AN
AMENDMENT CAN I BE A CO AUTHOR.
ANYONE IS FAMILIAR WITH THE
FINANCIAL ACCOUNTING STANDARDS
BOARD IS AS YOU ARE AS A WELCOME
TO BE CO AUTHOR YES SIR THANK
YOU SIR THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK MISTER TO
LETTER YES THANK YOU FOR BEING --
AS BOLD AS YOU ARE -- L. AS A
REAL ESTATE BROKER I KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF TITLE COMPANIES IN
TRANSACTION WITHOUT THE TITLE
COMPANIES A REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTIONS COULD OPEN OR
CLOSED.
THE ABSTRACT THE THE THE
SEARCHES AND EVERYTHING ELSE BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY TO PROTECT THE
CONSUMER.
AND TO GO IN DEPTH TO RESEARCH
THE PROPERTIES AND THEN TO
ENSURE DONNELLY THE LINES
BOUNDARIES THE HISTORY THE
PROPERTY SO I THINK THIS GIVES
YOU.
A STRONGER HOLD -- IS OBVIOUSLY
THE INDUSTRY TO SUPPORT THE
CONSUMER AND I'VE.
APPLIED YOUR YOUR BOULDER THANK
YOU JOHN.
ANY OTHER MEMBER WISHING TO
SPEAK.
THANK YOU WELL COMING FROM MUCH
X. EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA -- I'M
COUGHING AND IT'S A GOOD BILL SO --
MOVED BY MISTER MARLAND -- CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE.
THE PASS AS AMENDED RUBIO AYE
RUBIO AYE JONES JONES I
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA IBEATS BEATS AYE
BURGESS WE'RE JUST AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZIER GLAZER AYE HUESO.
HUESO AYE MITCHELL MORLOCK MORE
LIKE I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO ONLINE MARK ROTH.
NICE WORK WE COULD HAVE ELEVEN
VOTES WE WILL LEAVE THEIR ROLE
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU GENTLEMEN.
NEXT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO AB
EIGHT ONE AS OUR EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN I MUST ALI YOU MAY
[inaudible]
PROCEED.
THANK YOU AGAIN AND ONCE AGAIN
I'M ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS HOUSE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS -- AS MENTIONED ON
PAGE THREE OF THE ANALYSIS THE
INSOLVENCY OF MERCED CASUALTY
FOLLOWING THE CAMPFIRE LAST YEAR
ILLUMINATED THE LIMITATIONS OF
CURRENT LAW GOVERNING CLAIMS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA INSURANCE
GUARANTY ASSOCIATION.
KNOWN AS SEGA.
SEGA IS RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING
CLAIMS ONE OF PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURER BECOMES INSOLVENT.
EXCEPT FOR WORKERS COMPENSATION
CLAIMS EXISTING LAW CAPS SEE
GOOD CLAIMS FOR PROPERTY
CASUALTY AT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
OBVIOUSLY THE COST OF BUILDING
HAVE RISEN SIGNIFICANTLY CENSUS
CAP WAS ESTABLISHED. FIVE
DECADES AGO. FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH TO
REBUILD MANY HOMES IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY WITH THE INCREASED
COST OF BUILDING.
AFTER A MAJOR DISASTER.
THE BILL INCREASES THE CAT FOR
CLAIMS TO REPLACE TO REBUILD THE
HOME TO ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
IT ALSO CLARIFIES THAT THE
EXISTING FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR CAPS APPLY SEPARATELY TO
THE OTHER COVERAGES COMMONLY
FOUND IN A HOMEOWNER'S POLICY.
THESE OTHER COVERAGES COMMONLY
INCLUDE CONTENTS ADDITIONAL
LIVING EXPENSES AND OTHER
STRUCTURES.
MISTER MICHAEL MARTINEZ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE IS HERE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND THEY ARE
A SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
I JUST CALLED YOU MISTER DALI
YOUR COLLEAGUE THAT CAME OVER
FROM THE ASSEMBLY SO MY
APOLOGIES AFTER.
THINGS -- WELL I GET CALLED DOWN
ASSEMBLY REVIEW ALL THE TIME TOO
SO I BUT UP GO AHEAD SORRY FOR
THE INTERRUPTION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARC MARTINEZ HER
BEHALF OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA HE IS PROBABLY AS
SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE AND WANT
TO THANK THE SOME WOMEN FOR IS --
LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THIS
MEASURE AND ABSOLUTE GREW WITH
WHAT THE SOMEONE MINUTES STATED
I'VE EVER TO AND THE NEED FOR
THIS MEASURE.
BECAUSE REALLY MEAN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IS A VERY
OUTDATED NUMBER IT HAS BEEN
AROUND SINCE INCEPTION OF SEGA.
AND WE HAVE CONSIDERED IT
INSUFFICIENT ANOTHER -- ITEM
HERE IS THAT THE INCREASE OF THE
OF SUGGEST CAP BEING RAISED TO
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IS REFLECTED
AS A RECOMMENDATION IN THE
RECENT SB NINE A ONE COMMISSION.
REPORT THAT CAME OUT IN THE LAST
HANDFUL OF WEEKS AS A
RECOMMENDATION BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION FELT.
THE EXISTING CAP WOULD RESULT IN
A PAYMENT FROM SIR THERE WHICH
IS FAR BELOW.
THAT WHICH THE HOMEOWNER WOULD
HAVE OTHERWISE RECEIVE FROM
THEIR INSURER AND SO WITH THAT
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE I ALSO HAVE
HERE WITH ME LAWS LOW COMMUNITY.
WHO IS A LAWYER AT THE
DEPARTMENT TO ANSWER TO HELP
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THANK YOU?
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
A JOHN NOR WOULD ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TERMS GERRITY
ASSOCIATION JUST ONE INDICATOR
WERE FINE WITH THIS CHANGE AND
THERE WILL BE NO WAS NEW
ASSESSMENTS AS A RESULT OF THIS.
THE COUNTY ASSOCIATION HANDLED
WELL OVER TWO HUNDRED CLAIMS IN
PARADISE I THINK -- EXCELLENT
JOB THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
NETWORK ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO
SPEAK AND SUPPORTS.
ANYBODY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY COME UP
PLEASE.
SEE NO INTEREST MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS.
CENTER MORE LOG.
I'M I'M ASSUMING THERE'S NO COST
TO TAXPAYERS IS THAT A CORRECT
ASSUMPTION.
I BELIEVE SO.
NO THAT THERE SHOULD BE THE THE
COSTA FOR FOR SYRIA IT ACTUALLY
IS -- FOR THE THE THE THE CLAIMS
OR TAKEN FROM INSURERS THAT
RIGHT IN CALIFORNIA AND SO THAT
IS IN TURN WHERE THE COST BASED
ON THEIR MARKET SHARE.
THAT IS WHERE THE MONEY COMES
FROM WHICH ENTERED WHICH IN TURN
IS PAID OUT TO COVER CLAIMS THAT
ARE NOT COVERED -- IN ANY COURT
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDINGS COULD BE
A MODIFICATION TO THEIR PREMIUMS
[inaudible]
A NEW [inaudible]
OUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND AND A HALF WE CALCULATED.
THAT THE MINIMUS.
ALSO WHICH IS.
AS A IT NOW STANDS.
CATION HAVING AND BEING VERY.
THERE IS SUFFICIENT FUNDS THAT
SEEK A CURRENTLY.
TO ANALYZE THAT PLANS AND ONCE
THE POLICIES ARE TAKING CARE OF
AND THE LIQUIDATION OF LIKE THAT
CONTINUES.
ANY FUNDS THAT MERCED HAS TO GO
TOWARD IT FIRST THING IN
MINISTRY AND SAYS.
AND THEN REIMBURSING YOU GET TO
THE EXTENT NECESSARY THAT THE
HOUSE FUNDING BY.
THERE IS NO ANTICIPATION OF THIS
TIME.
AND IF ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
FUTURE IF YOU'RE SOME SHRINK
RECKON WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH
SOME MONEY WE JUST -- RELY ON
THE PERSONAL ASSETS OF RICARDO
LARA THAN [inaudible]
AT I DON'T KNOW IF.
THE LAR AS IN.
OKAY.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK.
WITHOUT UP MR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALY WOULD.
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I'M SORRY
MOTION MIGHT MISS ROGER LETTER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED RUBIO
AYE RUBIO AYE JONES.
JONES I ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA IBEATS.
BATES AYE BARGES BARGES AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER GLAZER AYE WE SO.
HUESO AYE MITCHELL MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE.
THIS TROUBLES AT THIS TIME WE
WILL HOLD THE ROPE IN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GENTLEMEN MAX.
THANK YOU -- I SEE MISTER
ARAMBULA HIM FACE.
COME UP WE'RE MOVING OVER.
TO AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I AM HERE
TO PRINT TODAY TO PRESENT ON A.
B. TWELVE TWENTY THREE REGARDING.
LIVING ORGAN DONATIONS.
NEARLY SIXTY NINE HUNDRED LIVING
ORGAN DONATIONS ARE DONE EACH
YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES AND
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO OF
THOSE WERE DONE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR MANY PATIENTS IN
ORGAN FAILURE AN ORGAN
TRANSPLANT.
CAN BE THEIR ONLY REMAINING
MEDICAL OPTION UNDER CURRENT LAW
LIVING ORGAN DONORS ARE ALLOWED
UP TO THIRTY DAYS OF PAID LEAVE
AFTER WHICH AFTER SURGERY TO
FULLY RECOVER.
JOHNS HOPKINS MEDICINE REPORTS
THAT FULL RECOVERY FROM ORGAN
DONATION TAKES AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR TO SIX WEEKS WITH SOME
PATIENTS NEEDING EVEN MORE TIME.
LIVING DONORS ALSO EXPERIENCE
DISCRIMINATION WITH SOME
INSURERS AND DO NOT HAVE
EXPLICIT JOB PROTECTION.
WHILE THEY RECOVER FROM ORGAN
DONATION SURGERY. FOR EXAMPLE A
STUDY FROM THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF HEALTH DEMONSTRATED
THAT A HIGH PROPORTION OF KIDNEY
DONORS HAD DIFFICULTY CHANGING.
OR INITIATING INSURANCE PLANS
AND IT WAS PARTICULARLY
DIFFICULT WITH LIFE INSURANCE.
AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE SIX TO
ADDRESS THESE HURDLES FOR ORGAN
DONATION WITH A TWO PRONGED
APPROACH.
FIRST AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE
WITHIN A LOT ALLOWING EMPLOYEES
TO TAKE AN ADDITIONAL ON PAID
LEAVE UP TO THIRTY BUSINESS DAYS.
IN A ONE YEAR PERIOD FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ORGAN DONATION.
THE BILL CLARIFIES THAT AN
EMPLOYEE MUST FIRST EXHAUST ALL
AVAILABLE SICK LEAVE BEFORE
TAKING THAT ON PAID LEAVE.
BY ADDING THIS.
OPTION FOR ADDITIONAL ON PAID
LEAVE IF NEEDED POTENTIAL ORGAN
DONORS WILL HAVE COMFORT KNOWING
THAT THEY CAN TAKE THE NECESSARY
TIME. FOR A FULL RECOVERY
WITHOUT FEAR OF LOSING THEIR
JOBS.
SECOND AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE
WOULD ALSO PROHIBIT INSURERS
FROM DECLINING READING OR
LIMITING COVERAGE OF A PERSON
UNDER A LIFE.
OR DISABILITY INSURANCE POLICIES
SOLELY DUE TO THE STATUS OF THE
PERSON AS A LIVING ORGAN DONOR.
THESE TWO APPROACHES AIMTO
REDUCE THE HURDLES FOR ORGAN
DONATION BY INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF SURGICAL RECOVERY TIME
BY THIRTY DAYS.
AND PROHIBITING DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST ORGAN DONORS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS SCOTT
SADLER WITH THE AMERICAN KIDNEY
FUND.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIRMAN RUBIO
VICE JIM JONES MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON A. B..
TWELVE TWENTY THREE THIS BILL
PROHIBITING TURNS DISCRIMINATION
BASED ON A PERSON'S STATUS AS AN
ORGAN DONOR.
AND ONE SURE ACCESS TO JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE FOR ORGAN DONORS.
I'M SCOTT SAILOR I REPRESENT THE
AMERICAN CAN YOU FIND A K. F. IS
AN INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT.
THAT FOR NEARLY FIFTY YEARS IS
HELP PEOPLE FIGHT KIDNEY DISEASE
AND LIVE HEALTHIER LIVES WE RUN
THE NATION'S LARGEST FREE KIDNEY
HEALTH SCREENING PROGRAM TO WORK
EVERY DAY TO HELP PEOPLE PREVENT
KIDNEY DISEASE AND DETECTED AS
EARLY AS POSSIBLE.
TRANSPORTATION AXES A LITERAL
LIFELINE FOR PATIENTS SUFFERING
FROM KIDNEY FAILURE OFFERING A
CHANCE FOR A LONGER HEALTHIER
LIFE.
BUT THE SEVERE SHORTAGE OF
AVAILABLE ORGANS THE UNITED
STATES MEANS THAT MORE THAN
NINETEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS ARE WAITING FOR A
KIDNEY DONATION.
WE BELIEVE THE AB TWELVE TWENTY
THREE WILL REMOVE BARRIERS TO
LIVING DOWN THE ORGAN DONATIONS.
AND WE BELIEVE THIS GUARANTEEING
JOB SECURITY WHEN THEY TAKE TIME
OFF TO RECOVER AND PROHIBITING
INSURERS DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
ORGAN DONORS.
IS SENSIBLE PUBLIC POLICY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME WE APPRECIATE
A AYE VOTE FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO SPEAK AND SUPPORT PLEASE COME
UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MCCUE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN SUPPORT
ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEDICINE BY ON
BEHALF OF DONATE LIFE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY GOSS ON
BEHALF OF DIALYSIS PATIENTS
CITIZENS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
KELLY BE MOM HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME UP.
SEE NO INTEREST MEMBERS.
THANK YOU ARE WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER ROTH BUT BEFORE WE
MOVE FORWARD I JUST WANT TO SAY
IT IS SOMETHING THAT I'VE ALWAYS
ADVOCATED FOR AND I SEE WE SEE
DONATE FOR LIFE FOR YEARS H.
PEOPLE TO TO PARTICIPATE NOT.
BUT BARRIERS SO THEY DON'T WANT
TO SELL THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD WITH THAT -- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE JONES.
JONES I ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA IBEATS.
BATES AYE BURGESS BURGESS AYE
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER.
WHERE I RUBIO HUESO?
HUESO AYE MITCHELL MORLOCK.
MORE LIKE I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH ROTH AYE.
TWELVE ZERO AT THIS TIME WILL
LIVE THE BILL CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I
SEE -- MISTER BERMAN HAS JOINED
US.
WE WILL BE HEARING AB TEN SIXTY
FIVE I MUST BERMAN YOU MAY
PROCEED THANKYOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS I'D
LIKE TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR THE
CONSIDERABLE TIME.
AND AND EFFORT HIS DEVOTED THIS
BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGES
FIVE AND SIX OF THE ANALYSIS
WHICH ADDED MINISTRY OF REMEDIES
AND ADDRESS DRAFTING
INCONSISTENCIES.
AB TEN SIXTY FIVE WOULD
INDEFINITELY EXTEND THE ABILITY
OF INSURERS TO OFFER CONSUMERS
THE OPTION OF RECEIVING CERTAIN
DOCUMENTS ELECTRONICALLY.
THE ADVANTAGES TO OPTIONAL
ELECTRONIC TRANSACTIONS ARE
NUMEROUS INCLUDING ADDITIONAL
CONSUMER CHOICE FASTER DELIVERY
REDUCED COST ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS OF GOING GREEN.
AND PORTABILITY.
AS THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS NOTES
IN THE AFTERMATH OF A DISASTER
SUCH AS A FIRE FLOOD OR MUD
SLIDE THE ABILITY FOR INSUREDS
WHO HAVE SUFFERED LOSSES AND
INSURERS. TO CONDUCT
TRANSACTIONS ELECTRONICALLY CAN
ACCELERATE THE RECOVERY PROCESS.
BECAUSE WE MAY BE DEALING WITH
IMPORTANT NOTICE TO CONSUMERS
THE LAW IMPOSES ADDITIONAL
SAFEGUARDS ON INSURERS IN ORDER
TO PROTECT THE CONSUMER. FOR
EXAMPLE A CONSUMER MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE RECEIPT OF SENSITIVE
DOCUMENTS TRANSMITTED
ELECTRONICALLY SO THAT I MISSED
EMAIL OR AN EMAIL THAT ENDS UP
CAUGHT IN THE SPAM FILTER WILL
NOT JEOPARDIZE INSURANCE
COVERAGE.
THIS HEIGHTENED STANDARD OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION IS GREATER
THAN THE LAW APPLICABLE FOR
PAPER DOCUMENTATION.
AS AMENDED A. B. TEN SIXTY FIVE
PERTAINS EXISTING CNSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
AND PUTS IN PLACE COMPLIANCE
ORIENTED REMEDIES WELL
PERMANENTLY PRESERVING THE
OPTION FOR CONSUMER TO CHOOSE
ELECTRONIC TRANSMISSION OF
INSURANCE DOCUMENTATION.
ACCORDINGLY I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
BY CONVERTING MISTER BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE AND REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS TO COMMITTEE.
OF BOTH COMMITTEES IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE WORKING ON THIS
LOSS SAID AMENDMENTS WHICH
REALLY HELP TO PROVIDE THE
COMMISSION TO BE.
VERY ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THE
PROMISE OF WHAT TECHNOLOGY CAN
BRING TO THE INSURANCE -- MARKET
PLACE AND SO WHAT THIS IT WAS
WITH THE AMENDMENTS OF PROVIDES
THE COMMISSIONER WITH ADDITIONAL
INTERMEDIATE ENFORCEMENT
PROCEDURES ON TOP OF THE
EXISTING -- ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS TO ENSURE SORT OF
THIS BALANCE AND HELP FOR
INSURERS TO CURE.
OF ANY PROBLEM WITHIN A
SPECIFIED TIME FRAMES WAS NOT
TERM CURE ADDITIONAL
INTERMEDIATE PENALTIES
ESPECIALLY IN AND TIMES WHEN
IT'S INNER INADVERTENT.
AND SWEET SO THIS IS REALLY GOOD --
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE AND WITHOUT
ASK HER AYE VOTE.
GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRY
MCCUE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
IN SUPPORT THE BILL WE TWO WOULD
LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS ARE OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
GOING FORWARD WE CERTAINLY HOPE
WE WILL SEE MORE INSURANCE
COMPANIES PROVIDING CONSUMERS
WITH THE OPTION TO BENEFIT FROM
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY TECHNOLOGY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SHARE RUMORS
ABOUT THE AMERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE STAFF IN THE AUTHORS OFFICE
FOR THEIR HARD WORK.
ON THE AMENDMENTS -- AND WORK
PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
CAN STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF ALL STATE INSURANCE IN
SUPPORT.
YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
NAMELY PICTURE WITH MAKE YOU CUT
CAN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
PACIFIC ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
THE NO INTEREST MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS.
MOVE THE BILL BY MISTER ROTH
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE
JONES JONES I ARCHULETA.
BUT YOU LET AYE BATES BATES AYE
BARGES DODD.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HUESO.
HUESO AYE MITCHELL MORE LOCK
MOORLACH AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH ROTH AYE
[inaudible] NINE WE'RE
CURRENTLY AT NINE VOTES WERE
GONNA BE THE THE CALL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- AT THIS TIME I'M GOING
TO GO BACK TO IT CONSENT
CALENDAR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ABOUT.
MOTION BY MISTER OUT THANK YOU.
THE PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS CONSENT CALENDAR
RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE JONES JONES I
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA IBEATS BATES AYE
BORGIAS.
DODD [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
I HUESO.
HUESO AYE MITCHELL MORE LOCK
MOORLACH AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH ROTH AYE.
TEN ZERO I WILL.
CONSIDER IT LEAVE THE CALL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ARE I MEAN IF
THE CALL ON I'M SO SORRY --
MISTER COOLEY YOU MAY PROCEED.
I ALMOST FORGOT YOU MY APOLOGIES --
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO AB
FIFTEEN NINETY ONE MISTER COOLEY
[inaudible]
I KNOW.
WE'LL CALL IN A PRESCRIPTION TO
BE HERE IN THE SENATE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE PRESIDENT AB.
FIFTEEN NINETY ONE THE BACKSTORY
THIS MEASURE REALLY THE THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY IS UNIQUE IN
THE SENSE THAT.
MANY OF THE KEY RULES AFFECTED
INSURANCE COME OUT OF A PROCESS
WHERE THERE'S A NATIONAL BODY.
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS A PRIVATE BODY.
THE PROVIDES A VENUE FOR THE
REGULARS ALL FIFTY STATES TO
DISCUSS.
NATIONAL INSURANCE MARKETPLACE
ISSUES.
AND OUT OF THAT BODY THEY
PROMULGATE DRAFT MODEL LOS
[inaudible]
MODEL REGULATIONS.
YOUR CUSTOMER THINK OF YOURSELF
YOU'RE THE LEGISLATOR YOU
ACTUALLY PASSED THE LOS BUT THE
ANY ICY.
PROMULGATES MODEL LAWS AND
REGULATIONS.
THEY HAVE AN ACCREDITATION
PROGRAM THAT A INSURANCE
DEPARTMENT CAN ONLY GET
ACCREDITED.
IF YOU HAVE ALL THESE LAWS IN
PLACE THEY HAVE VARIOUS CRITERIA --
SO YOU HAVE IN THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY.
IT THE WHOLE SYSTEM REGULATIONS
FOUNDED UPON A DELEGATION.
OF LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY TO A
PRIVATE PARTY THE ANY I SEE.
WE HAVE IN OUR CODES MANY OF
THESE STATUTES IN PLACE -- WE
ACTUALLY HAVE PROVISIONS THAT.
IN HERE MARKET CONDUCT TO SAY
OUR LAW INCORPORATES THE WORK OF
THE ANY I SEE THEIR MARKER
CONDUCT MANUAL.
IN THIS MOST RECENT ITERATION.
WHICH ACTUALLY MEANS THEY COULD
CHANGE THE RULES TOMORROW.
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN IT AND IS
INCORPORATED BY REFERENCE INTO
OUR STATUTE THAT IS A CLASS OF
DELEGATIONS FUTURE DELEGATES
WHICH IS VERY UNUSUAL.
IN OUR SYSTEM OF LAW.
ALL THIS BILL DOES IS IT SAYS
GIVEN THIS BACKDROP.
THAT THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
RELIES UPON THIS DELEGATED
AUTHORITY.
THAT ON EVERY TWO YEAR CYCLE THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER SHOULD
PROVIDE A BRIEFING TO THE STATE
LEGISLATOR.
THE RELEVANT BUDGET CRUISER
OVERSEE INSURANCE ON THE POLICY
COMMITTEES.
ON WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON THE ANY
I SEE THE SYSTEM OF
ACCREDITATION HOW IT'S WORKED
ANY CHANGES SINCE THE LAST --
LAST BRIEFING -- SO THE
BASICALLY THE LAWMAKERS WHO ARE
DELEGATED THIS AUTHORITY WILL BE
KEPT CURRENT ON WHAT IS THE
CONVERSATION THAN A I SEE.
IT ALSO ENCOURAGES THAT THE
INSURANCE DEPARTMENT SHOULD
SUPPORT.
THE CHAIRS LIKE WATER TO MEMBER
CYNOSURE SCREENING EACH HOUSE
BUDGET COMMITTEE REPRESENT. TO
ACTUALLY HAVE THE OPTION TO GO
BACK AND WATCH WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE ICY.
AND A COMPANION ORGANIZATION THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF INSURANCE
LEGISLATORS.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
IS NATIONAL COUNCIL INSURANCE
LEGISLATORS ARE STRICTLY
LAWMAKERS.
THE CONVENE PERIODICALLY TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S HOT.
ON INSURANCE FRONT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO KNOW
ABOUT.
ARE THE DIVERSITY GOING TO THOSE
TO ME IS IF YOU GO TO THE ANY I
SEE IT'S LIKE.
YOU WANT TO SEE WHAT'S WHAT
PLANTS ARE IN THE WORLD YOU JUST
WALK OUT OF THE FOREST.
IT'S VERY CONFUSING TO SPEND A
FEW DAYS IT MAY I SEE ALL THE
TOPICS UNDER CONSIDERATION TO
GET UP TO SPEED WALKING OFF THE
STREET AS OLD.
AS A MEMBER THE PUBLIC IS VERY
HARD IT'S KIND OF CHAOTIC.
IN COIL IS MORE OF A FOCUS CITY
WHERE YOU'D BE YOU'D BE SEEN
WITH OTHER LAWMAKERS THERE'S AN
AGENDA THEIR SPREE FEEDS.
REALLY DESIGNED EIGHT EIGHT THE
QUICK LAWMAKERS SO I VIEW THIS
BILL IS ISN'T KNOWLEDGE MEN OF
THIS DELEGATION ISSUE.
THE IMPORTANCE OF LAWMAKERS
BEING INFORMED ON PUBLIC POLICY
THE C. GET MATTER THAT THE
GUARANTEE FUND YOU JUST TALK
ABOUT THAT'S ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
ACCREDITED STANDARD STATUTES IN
CALIFORNIA.
A IT'S JUST DESIGNED TO ENSURE
THAT LAWMAKERS WHO ARE THE
SOURCE OF THIS DELEGATED POWER
ACTUALLY SORT OF HAVE A HANDLE
ON WHAT'S ONE OF THE HOT ISSUES
WHAT'S CURRENT.
AND TRADITIONALLY AND I WOULD
EXPECT THAT WILL CONTINUE
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY PAYS THE
LEGISLATURE PAYS OUR MEMBERSHIP
IN NATIONAL COUNCIL INSURANCE
LEGISLATORS I WOULD NOT EXPECT
THAT TO CHANGE.
BUT IT DOES ASK THE DEPARTMENT
SURE IS TO KIND OF COORDINATE
WITH HELPING GET SOME LAWMAKERS
OUR THEY ACTUALLY SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON SO THAT'S THE BACK ROW
THIS BILL I THINK IT IS FOR THE
GOOD OF OUR OUR OUR WORKERS
LAWMAKERS.
THE CENTRALITY OF LAW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE ABOUT NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WE'VE HAD
AN INSURANCE CODE PROVISION.
TWELVE NINE TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
THIS IS INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
JOBS WITH MINISTER ALL THESE
STATUTES. FOR THEIR JOB IS TO
FIND OUT WHAT IS ON THE BOOKS.
THE LECTURE JUST PUT THERE THIS
BILL JUST SUPPORTS THE REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
YES -- THORN CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY STEP FORWARD.
THE NO INTEREST MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS.
NO -- BRIGHTEN THE MIDDLE JUST
AND WITH NO POSITION THE
INSURANCE ¯E
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER.
RICARDO LARA AND WE DO NOT HAVE
A POSITION HE DOES NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT ON THIS MEASURE
APPRECIATE ALL THE FEEDBACK AND
DIALOGUE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
HAVING WITH AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF.
AND LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
DIALOGUE IS THIS -- ON ON JUST A
COUPLE MORE TINY QUESTIONS ARE
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD TO
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER MARTINEZ -- MISTER
GLAZER -- THANK YOU I I LIKE THE
BILL I THINK IT MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE -- I THINK IT'S A BONUS
THAT IT DOESN'T SAY THAT
COMMISSIONER OR IS DESIGNATES AS
THE COMMISSIONER.
AND OUT AS MUCH AS I LOVE OUR
DOES IT NEED A NICE TO HAVE OUR
GOOD FRIEND BACK HERE IN FRONT
OF US -- TO BE ANY OF OUR YEAR.
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS SO WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS MR
JOHNSON.
THANK YOU JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS MOVING CAR FIVE ME IF
I AND REMEMBER CORRECTLY
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE
WITH AN ELECTED INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER IS THAT CORRECT ALL
I DON'T KNOW THE WERE THE ONLY.
ONE BUT IT WAS AN APPOINTED
POSITION UNTIL PROP ONE OF THREE
PASSED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT REGARDING
IS FOR TWO QUESTIONS --
REGARDING THE DELEGATED POWERS
WHY DON'T WE JUST.
ELIMINATE THAT ASPECT -- OF THAT
AGREEMENT -- SO THAT
[inaudible]
ALL ALL.
ISSUES HAVE TO COME BACK TO US
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IF THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER DECIDES
HE'S NOT GOING TO COMPLY WITH
THIS WHAT'S THE ENFORCEMENT.
PROCESS.
THE RESPONSES ON THAT I THINK TO
CHANGE THE DATE FOR THE INTEREST
CHRIS OF POSITION WOULD YOU DO
TO VOTE OF THE PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY PROP ON ALL THREE
WERE STRUCTURED.
YEAH I'M JUST I'M NOT ADVOCATING
FOR ELIMINATING ELECTED
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER OF RIGHT
I WAS JUST STATING THAT AS A
YEAH THAT'S SO THAT'S THAT'S A
GIVEN -- LET'S SEE NOW THE FIRST
QUESTION THEN AFTER THAT YOU
MENTIONED.
YEAH I DELEGATED POWERS -- YEAH
I THINK -- AS A PRACTICAL MATTER
ANY AS HE DOES PER PROMULGATE
THESE MODELS AND THEY OFTEN COME
BEFORE US.
I WILL SAY IN MY CAREER WHEN
I'VE SERVED AS A CONSULTANT TO
THIS COMMITTEE -- AND IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND NINETEEN EIGHTIES
FOR ITS ASSEMBLY INSURANCE
COMMITTEE.
IT WAS ALWAYS MY RECOMMENDATION
IT WHAT IT WHAT THE AN ICY CAME
FORWARD WITH WAS A MODEL LAW OR
MODEL REGULATION.
THE HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
JUST TREAT THEM AS SOME TO WE
WOULD ADOPT BY STATUTE.
WE WOULD BE IN CONTROL OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS NOT THAT THINGS
GET PROPOSES REGULATIONS GOING
TO DOCTORS REGULATIONS WE'VE
NEVER SEEN.
SO I DO THINK AN ACTIVE INTEREST
BY POLICY MAKERS IN THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEES CAN CAN
KIND OF CONTROL THIS THIS IS
PART OF WHAT THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT.
ON THIS OTHER ISSUE VIS A VIS
DID NOT COMPLY I THINK THAT'S
WHY WE PASSED A STATUTE
[inaudible]
THE THE OR SOURCE OF THIS BILL.
NOT UNDER OUR CURRENT INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER BUT IN TIMES PAST.
I HAD REACHED OUT TO THE ANY I
SEE.
REQUESTED THEY MIGHT COME TO
SACRAMENTO.
AND PROVIDE A BRIEFING ON WHAT
THEY WOULD DO WHAT THEY DO.
BECAUSE RESIST DELEGATED POWER.
AND IN THOSE DAYS THEY SAID WELL
WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU.
AND WHAT ENSUED WAS A REACHED
OUT TO THE THE DENTURES
TREASURER OF THE TIME.
CALIFORNIA WHO SAYS NO I DON'T
WANT TO COME TO CALIFORNIA AND
THAT INITIATIVE ONE AWAY.
SO THIS IS ACTUALLY A WAY TO
KIND OF DO SOME STATUE TO SET US
MAKE SURE.
LAWMAKERS GET A BRIEFING GET A
CUSTOM TO KIND OF KEEPING TABS
ON ANY I SEE.
AND IF THEY WISH TO GO A COUPLE
TIMES YOU'RE IN COIL KIND OF
LEARN WHAT'S HOT AND KERR
DEBATES.
AND I ACTUALLY I'M AN OFFICER
NOW IN IN C<c.cyan> LIKE SAY YOU GO</c>
THERE.
IN A COUPLE OF DAYS YOU'LL GET A
SENSE OF WHAT'S COMING OUT OF
THE EUROPEAN UNION THAT MATTERS
WHAT'S HAPPENED FEDERAL LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT.
IT IS A STATE BASED REGULATION
BUT BECAUSE OF PRIVACY ISSUES OF
FINANCIAL CRISES THE FEDS HAVE
MORE OF A ROLE.
IT'S A WAY TO KIND OF SPEND A
LITTLE PLAY SPENT A COUPLE DAYS
WITH YOUR COLLEAGUES OTHER
STATES.
AND COME AWAY MUCH MORE IN
COMMAND OF THE SUBJECT MATTER OF
THIS PANEL.
I THINK I UNDERSTAND ALL THAT
BUT HOW YOU GONNA FORCE HIM TO
CALM OR HER CALM IF HE DOESN'T.
WANT TO OUR SHE DOESN'T WANT TO
OUR WELL I THINK THEN YOU YOU
START PUTTING PRESSURE ON THE
ANY I SEE AND SO YOU WATER.
ARRANGE FOR THIS -- MAYBE IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS IN FUTURE YEARS
IF WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THIS --
THAT MIGHT BE THE TOOL THAT WE
THERE YOU GO BECAUSE THE STATUTE
DOES CONCLAVE USEFUL EDUCATE OUR
BUDGET.
THANK YOU MISTER ROCK THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MYCOLOGIST ABOUT THE
DELEGATION OF AUTHORITY WITH
REGARD TO THE DELEGATION OF
AUTHORITY NO THE ANALYSIS OF
WE'VE BEEN PROVIDED INDICATES.
INCORPORATION BY REFERENCE
ALLOWS NON CONTROVERSIAL
TECHNICAL AND PROCEDURAL CHANGES
TO BECOME LAW WITHOUT DEBATE OR
SCRUTINY.
ASSUME THAT'S THE DELEGATION
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SIR YEAH
THAT WOULD BE -- THAT IS
CERTAINLY -- AN ASPECT OF IT I
MEAN I WOULD SAY.
THE MAN DOES IT EXTEND BEYOND
THAT.
WELL I'LL SAY THIS THE ANY MORE
ANY OF THESE MODELS THERE
EIGHTEEN MODEL STATUTES ARE
GENERALLY A PRODUCT OF PROBABLY
TWO OR THREE YEARS OF OF DEBATES
AND DISCUSSIONS INSIDE THE ANY I
SEE.
AND SO WE NEVER KIND OF
TYPICALLY ARE PARTICIPATING HAVE
ARE HERE THE GROUND HERE IN ONE
OF THE TRADE OFFS BEING MADE.
THEY END UP WITH A DOCUMENT
WHICH IS OUR MODEL STATUTE THEY
BRING TO US AND ASK US
INTRODUCED. THREE YOU KNOW WORDS
DO MATTER AND THERE CAN BE
SUBTLETIES OF WORDING THAT
REPRESENTS SOME TRADE OFF THAT
HAPPENED IN A I SEE.
WHICH ACTUALLY MAYBE SOME
SERVICE IMPACT WE MAY NOT SEE IT --
MUST BE UP THERE MUST BE A A
PROTOCOL THAT WE'VE SIGNED.
WELL I THINK WE I MEAN I WOULD
SAY IN OUR INSURANCE CODE FOR
EXAMPLE THE MARKER CONDUCT AREA
WE JUST HAVE A PROVISIONS SAYS.
THE MARKET CONDUCT GUIDE OF THE
ANY I SEE AS A CURRENT EXIST OR
FUTURE EDITIONS.
OUR OUR THE ONE THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT [inaudible]
RUNS WITH.
SO THAT'S THAT COULD BE MORE
THAN JUST TECHNICAL CHANGES WELL
I MEAN LET ME AS COULD TO THE
DIFFERENT WAYS SO WITH REGARD TO
THE IN A I SEE SO.
THE IN A I SEE COULD ADOPT A
MODEL CODE HAVING TO DO WITH
UNINSURED UNDERINSURED.
AND IT WOULD AUTOMATICALLY BE
INCORPORATED INTO OUR WELL IT WE
WOULD HAVE TO ADOPTED WE WE HAVE
TO ACT UPON THEIR MODELS.
BUT THEY COULD ADOPT A MODEL
WHICH WE MIGHT CONSIDER
CONTROVERSIAL.
AND THEY CAN INCORPORATED IN
THEIR ACCREDITATION SYSTEM.
AND THEN WE SORT OF HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF A WE WE NEED TO
KIND OF BACK UP OUR INTEREST
FORMER SAY WELL.
THAT'S YOUR MODEL IS TWENTY YEAR.
THINGS THAT YOU MEASURE WHETHER
AN INSURANCE FARMERS ACCREDITED
BUT WE ACTUALLY AS POLICY MAKERS
IN CALIFORNIA OF A DIFFERENT
VIEW SO APPARENTLY THEY'RE TWO
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES SO IF IT IS.
IF THE SUBJECT IS NON
CONTROVERSIAL TECHNICAL OR
PROCEDURAL IT CAN SIMPLY SLIDE
RIGHT INTO OUR INSURANCE CODE
WITHOUT COMING HERE.
BUT IF IT'S SOMETHING
SIGNIFICANT IT HAS TO COME HERE
AND WE HAVE TO DEBATE AND VOTE
ON IT I WOULD SAY I MEAN I'M
GONNA SAY. THIRTY ASKED YOU HAVE.
THEY CAN'T PASS A MODEL.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY PASSED A
MODEL IT'LL HAVE NO AFFECT US IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE ONLY WILL BECOME EFFECTIVE
IN CALIFORNIA IS IF BECAUSE
INTRODUCES A BILL.
AND GOES TO OUR PROCESS.
YOU KNOW THIS THE STANDARD IS
REAR ENACT NO LOCKS UP BY A
STATUTE NEW STATUTES UP BY BILL
THAT STILL APPLIES.
IF THEY GO THE REGULATORY ROUTE
THEY FEEL THEY HAVE SOME
AUTHORITY OR IN THE STATUTE.
THEN MAYBE THERE ARE MODEL
REGULATION GETS.
PROMULGATED BY INSTRUCTORS AS A
MODEL REGULATION STILL HAS TO GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS -- I AM
JUST A PROPONENT FOR LAWMAKERS
TO KIND OF UNDERSTAND.
WHAT IS REPRESENTED THESE MODELS
WHEN THEY COME FORWARD?
AND MAYBE SOME OF THE BACKSTORY
CONVERSATION.
SO THAT WE HAVE A MORE INFORMED.
VIEW OF WHAT WE ARE ADOPTING.
WHAT IT IS?
ALSO.
IT'S AN INTERESTING CONVERSATION
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE VOTING
ON YEAH I MEAN I DO THINK THAT
WE DO HAVE PROVISIONS ON THE
CODE THAT SAY.
THE MOST CURRENT EDITION FOR
EXAMPLE THE MARKET CONDUCT EXAM
BOOK OF THE HANDBOOK OF THE IN A
I SEE IS ONE THE CONTROLS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT AUTHORITIES RIGHT THERE IN
THE CODE AND IT'S SAYS THE
CURRENT VERSION OR FUTURE
VERSIONS WILL CONTROL.
AND YOU'LL NEVER SEE YOU DON'T
NECESSARY SEE THE CHANGES THAT
BETWEEN THIS ADDITION AND AN
EXPEDITION.
THAT'S A MORE CLASSIC
INCORPORATION BY REFERENCE
BECAUSE THEY JUST ADOPTED A NEW
HANDBOOK.
AND IT AND IT'S ON OUR BOOKS
BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS FUTURE.
DELEGATION PIECE ESTIMATING.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU MANAGER.
QUESTION TOUGH QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
EDUCATION I'M TO APPRECIATE YOUR
DEPTH OF KNOWLEDGE IN AS IT
PERTAINS TO INSURANCE SO THANK
YOU.
I WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLSE A REQUEST DR -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU -- MOTION.
MOVING ON BY MISTER WEST
SOMEPLACE COLORADO.
THE PAST THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS RUBIO AYE AYE
RUBIO AYE A JONES JONES I
ARCHULETA.
BUT YOU LET AYE BEATS.
BATES I BOARD JUST.
GORGEOUS AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
HUESO.
HUESO AYE MITCHELL MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE I TWENTY NOW.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
ROTH I AT THIS TIME YOU HAVE
TWELVE VOLTS WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA GO ONTO
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE SECOND.
HALF.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TO MOVE
CHAU -- THE CONSENT CALIBER A
SENATOR WAS -- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE CURRENT VERSION IS TEN ZERO
GORGEOUS. FOR A. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE CONSENT FOR
JUST AYE DODD.
DODD I CAN CALL.
pWE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO AB TWO
NINETY FIVE DALY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ROTH RIGHT ROTH HI [inaudible]
CALL.
WE'RE GONNA PAY THE BOND KHôNG
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO AB
FIVE FORTY EIGHT FROM RODRIGUEZ
PLEASE CALL.
THE ROLL.
JONES.
JONES I DODD.
DODD AYE MITCHELL PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH ROTH AYE
[inaudible] TWELVE WE HAVE
CURRENTLY TWELVE VOTER IN A
PLACE THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS -- WE'RE MOVING ON TO AB
SEVEN FOUR ZERO BY BURKE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ROTH I BECAUSE MANY.
WE'RE GONNA PLACE THE BILL ON
CALM UP WE'RE MOVING ON TO AB
TEN SIXTY FIVE BY BERMAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB TEN SIXTY FIVE BY MISTER
BERMAN.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR GORGEOUS. FOR
THIS AYE DODD.
I GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MITCHELL.
IT GOES ON CALL.
WE HAVE -- WE HAVE.
PHOTOS THE BEST.
ONE THAT NUMBER HAS TWELVE THOSE
ARE IN A PLACE THAT BACK ON PALM --
WE'RE MOVING ON TO A. B. TWELVE
TWENTY THREE AB FROM MISTER
ARAMBULA.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
WERE STILL WAITING FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ARE WE CURRENTLY HAVE THE ARM.
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE GOING ON
WE'RE MISSING TO MEMBERS ARE
GONNA TAKE A BRIEF RECESS FOR A
FEW MINUTES HE WE CAN GET MISS
MITCHELL -- TO JOIN US THANK YOU.
CAN YOU CHECK ON THEM CLOSER.
NOW.
WITH COMMON HELP THE HELP
.
OKAY LET'S -- OPEN THE ROLE FOR
OUR ABSENT NOW PRESENT MEMBER
CENTER MITCHELL
FOR A. B. TEN
SIXTY FIVE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTERS TWELVE ZERO
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE THAT BILL IS OUT.
THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
A. B. TWELVE TWENTY THREE DO
PASSED THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTERS TWELVE
ZERO MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE THIRTEEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT [inaudible]
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible] SEVEN AB
FIFTEEN NINETY ONE TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT LOTUS TWELVE ZERO
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE THAT BILLS OUT.
THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN TO PASS AS
AMENDED.
KERN VOTERS TWELVE ZERO MITCHELL.
MITCHELL ARE THAT BILLS OUT.
THIRTEEN ZERO CONSENT ITEM ITEM
NUMBER.
SIX THE PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES
CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT VOTERS
TWELVE ZERO MITCHELL.
MITCHELL ARE THAT BUILD UP.
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT WAS THAT WE
CONCLUDED ALL BUSINESS BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE CONCLUDED ALL BUSINESS
LAYS IN GERMAN THIS OF HEARING
IS ADJOURNED